la malaisie s'étaient préparés mais
cette année le forum asie pacifique se
déroule à distance en raison de la crise
sanitaire
l'apec le forum de la coopération
économique pour l'asie-pacifique et
virtuels une première dans l'histoire de
l'institution
si l'on regrette l'absence des
participants le pays hôte n'oublie pas
les objectifs de cette édition 2020 la
région renforcera également son soutien
un système commercial multilatéral fondé
sur des règles qui fonctionne bien tout
en restant déterminés à faire avancer le
programme de développement de l'om c'est
ce jeudi
setchine jean ping qui a ouvert le
sommet le président chinois n'a pas
perdu de temps et a tout de suite montré
la volonté de son pays d'être le porte
étendard du libre échange
l'ouverture est ce qui permet un pays
d'aller de l'avant
alors que l' isolement le fred dans le
monde d'aujourd'hui où la mondialisation
économique est devenue une tendance
irréversible
aucune nation ne peut se développer en
maintenant ses portes fermées nous
encourageons la coopération avec toute
autre région du pays où entreprises qui
le souhaitent
un discours qui intervient quatre jours
après la signature du plus grand accord
commercial au monde
à l'initiative de pékin l'apec est donc
un moyen pour la chine d'affirmer un peu
plus sa puissance au sein du forum où
les états unis se font de plus en plus
absent sous l'administration trump guidé
par son slogan l'amérique d'abord
washington ne devrait d'ailleurs pas
intervenir pendant le sommet ce qui
laisse la voie libre à la chine
d'autres pays vont également prendre la
parole notamment la russie dès ce
vendredi par la voix de son président
vladimir poutine